كل شيء ينهار
أم
نحن بحاجة إلى فرق إنقاذ الناس
متطوعون
أم
أعني كما
قلت يجب على المجتمع الدولي
التحرك على الفور وإيجاد
طرق جوية وبرية لدخول
فرق الإنقاذ والمركبات كما
يفعلون عادة في الكوارث المماثلة
المدنيين المدنيين  هناك يستخدمون أيديهم العارية في
الحفر وإزالة الأنقاض
بحثًا عن أحبائهم،
ويمكن سماع صرخات الاستغاثة
من تحت الأنقاض، وفوق كل شيء،
يواجه الناجون
كوارث ثانوية حيث يخلق الطقس البارد
حالة مروعة
تعرض حياتهم للخطر.
اسمع أه
الزلازل
عندما تحدث كوارث أو الزلازل
ليس لها حدود
فلماذا تحرم الحدود والسياسة
المدنيين السوريين في شمال غرب
البلاد من حقوقهم الإنسانية
ليتم إنقاذهم ماذا تنتظر الأمم المتحدة
هذا يؤسفني أن أقول  أنا
أجنبي
آسف لقول أن هذه
إبادة دولية لملايين المدنيين
نعم إنها مأساة
يجب أن تؤثر السياسة على
إيصال المساعدات هناك وكما تقول فإن
الكثير من الناس يعانون أقصدك
أم نفسك مثل الكثيرين الذين غادروا سوريا
لديك علاقة معقدة مع
البلد لأنك كنت تخشى على
سلامتك واضطررت إلى مغادرة البلد
لست وحدك كيف يتجمع المجتمع السوري أه
المغتربين واللاجئين
للمساعدة بينما يتعاملون معهم أيضًا
أولئك الذين يشعرون بالقلق من أن تبرعاتهم قد
تنتهي في الأيدي الخطأ،
هذا هو ما يريحني، هذا هو
الجانب المريح من القصة، أنا
والناس في كل الكوارث أجد
الشعب السوري من جميع أنحاء البلاد
يجتمعون معًا من القلب إلى القلب يدًا إلى
يد كتفًا.  أن يتحملوا
مشاعر حقيقية لمساعدة أحبائهم الأشخاص الذين
يعرفون أنهم لا يعرفون،
ويمكنني أن أسمع على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الكثير من
الأصوات تجتمع معًا
وتجمع القوة والأمل
عندما تشعر بالتخلي عن هذا الأمر ثقيل جدًا
على القلب والعقل
و  في الوقت نفسه،
مع العلم أننا نستريح ضد الزمن، أشعر
بشعور مختلط عندما أشعر أن
الجهد يجب أن يكون ضخمًا للغاية
لتجميعه لمساعدة هؤلاء الأشخاص
وعندما تعلم أنه لا يوجد وقت
للقيام بذلك  نعم